[Music]
[Applause]
he's the Hall of Famer Bill Walton and
uh it's called throw it down with Bill
how would Bill Walton say this Seton
throw it down throw it down throw it
down down
please I came here to see somebody throw
it down and shoot jumpers out there
let's go so yeah our hero the standard
of Excellence the search for Perfection
yeah it all comes to be good morning sir
good morning Bill uh yeah seton's been
working on his Bill Walton impersonation
um you want to give us give us a little
Grateful Dead feel here wake now Dan and
discover that you are the song the
morning brings recognizing that
everything is led up to this day and yet
it's a day unlike any other that's ever
been we will survive we will get by get
up get up get out the door my friends
and throw it down big man get up get off
get on the door
did a remarkable job the whole team was
over the top Dome Productions in
conjunction with the NBA but I just want
to know if she is that is that the
Seaton for Seton Hall and was he using
chat GPT to come up with that script
that is that is a seating for Seton Hall
as a matter of fact yeah my dad went
there well fantastic you're like Bobby
Hurley there naming his children Cameron
that's it yeah yeah but Seton didn't get
into Seton Hall
really my son would be named uh
Mountaineer yeah he went to West
Virginia
yeah okay yeah I'm named Bill I'm named
it I'm named after my dad and my dad was
the greatest dad ever he had zero
interest in sports I never talked sports
with him I never watched sports with
them I never played sports with him but
I let him down I let him down because I
was 23 when we had our first child Adam
who was here yesterday lived up the
street and
my dad I'm the third and my dad wanted a
fourth and I was not old enough I was
not mature enough to want to burden one
of our children with Mining and then the
other time was when the end of the line
from my dad and I was running the show
there for everybody and everything
because we just lived 10 minutes away
from my parents home and my dad was in
and out of the hospital a lot at the
very end he was 83 years old and he kept
telling me Bill I don't want to die in
the hospital I don't want to die in the
hospital and so we were always calling
9-1-1 they were all our friends it all
grew up a very close Community where I
come from and so the paramedics were
always there in and out taking my dad
back and forth to the hospital and this
one time I mean I was there and we
called 9-1-1 and my dad said bill I
don't want to go to the hospital I don't
want to die in the hospital I thought we
could still save them they put them in
the ambulance I had the ambulance door
and he's looking at me and he's got
tears in his eyes and he said I don't
want to go to the hospital bill but I
close the door ambulance went off I
followed him to the hospital and he
never got out and it was something that
I wish I had known better when my mom
passed a year ago uh I knew better you
know I was just in my early 50s when my
dad passed so it was not 19 years ago
cheer it up a little bit here pick this
thing up let's throw it down one time uh
if you didn't go to UCLA where were you
going
UCLA
there was no second choice no second
choice and I'm reading a brilliant book
right now I know you're a reader and you
love books and knowledge and everything
one of my teammates the winningest
player in the history of college
basketball Larry Farmer got a brand new
book out Santa Monica press it's called
the role of a lifetime and Larry's
experience was totally different than
mine and although
in many ways it was totally similar
because we played for the same coach we
were he was the starter for two years on
on our first two championships there
undefeated uh never lost a game with
Larry in the starting lineup there and
he played with Sydney Rick's in the in
his sophomore year an era of three years
of college basketball and it's just a
beautiful read and it's a fun upbeat
happy book and all the different things
that went down and the way that Larry's
able to turn the phrase to to make it so
real so inviting so enveloping which was
what UCLA was all about and so many
spectacular people yes we had John
Wooden as great a coach as there's ever
been but we also had JD Morgan as great
an athletic director as there's ever
been we had Chancellor Young Who was the
chancellor at UCLA for 29 years I mean
that's a job to just choose people up
and spits them out in public education
and then we had ducky Drake Lucky Drake
got there in 1923 and he died in 1988
and I can't even do the math anymore
that I think that's 65 years but he was
the trainer he was the track coach he
was Rayford Johnson and CK Yang's
coaching but he was the the conduit that
was that understood young people's
problems and was able to be the sounding
board and and be the buffer between
Chancellor Young Jay Morgan John Wooden
and all the players it was it was a
phenomenal experience for me I wish it
had lasted forever what would you have
made with name image and likeness at
UCLA I was doing a show one time with
Kareem and and we got to the Q a and and
they asked to read we always defer to to
Kareem you know the greatest player I
ever played against the standard of
Excellence and so we'll get to Kareem
and his records and and Lebron in a
moment but we're sitting there and it
goes to the Q a and
and they said if you had played in the
in the era of nil
what would you have made and he looked
at me and and he looked back at the
crowd he said
Europe
and then he looked over at me and he
said and Bill would have got South
America
and so as I was watching the LeBron's
game the other night I mean just his
last game uh I don't know exactly when
they're playing again but
I saw him play against the Blazers I was
prepping for uh throw it down Spurs had
Blazers and I'm watching this guy and it
you know it was I I think it was 20
years ago well maybe even more when he
first started at St Mary's St Vincent's
and we went over there and into
Cleveland State and did that first game
when he was in high school we did the
second game when he was in uh at playing
at Poly Pavilion because it was it was
so spectacular when he was 18 years old
and now here he is I believe he's 38 now
and what he was doing in that game at 38
years old that he is not backing into
this record no I mean this is a
staggering accomplishment of everything
but did you think Kareem's record would
ever be approached you always think that
and I was there when real was setting
all his records right and then Kareem
starts catching him right and it will
was fantastic and that was a huge
influence in my life I've been the
luckiest guy in the world and so when
Kareem was coming up the world would get
super mad in my early days of
broadcasting for the Clippers when I
would talk about wilt's records this was
you know in the 90s and early 90s and 33
years ago now and and I would always
refer to it you know as uh when will
would miss 5 000 free throws in his
career and that real would call me I
would say hey Billy don't talk about
that if I thought that was important I
would have made them right then when
Kareem was coming to pass him and and
break his records uh well you know he he
would say to all of us and these were
you know personal conversation Jack
because Wilt was just an incredible
human being he was a combination of
personality wise of Magic Johnson and
Santa Claus and so when you would ask
when you you know when you would be
talking and Kareem was coming up
and the level of skill Talent dedication
determination durability that it takes
to do something like that is just off
the charts Indescribable and so as
Kareem is you know inching up and going
to get there and I was watching the game
when cream swung the Skyhook and Mark
Eaton's face and hit it in Las Vegas and
and so
Wilt would say
Billy if if I thought anybody was ever
going to break my records I just would
have doubled them up because you know in
those days
a lengthy career was 10 12 a Dozen Years
13 years and you know today's players
this is to take nothing away from
today's players and these guys are
spectacular the level of physical
fitness and it's one of the things that
just blows me away about LeBron is that
here he is 38 and he is still the most
active guy in the game and he is running
so fast and attacking the rim and
throwing it down and then he shoots
jumpers and when I watch LeBron I I I
can never figure out what the best part
of his game is I mean here's a guy who
you know who in any particular moment
any particular game any particular event
he can be the best shooter the best
passer the best dribbler the best
rebounder the best defender and the the
best shot blocker the best screener the
best he can do everything out there and
he's still doing it as well if not
better than anybody else in the game at
Portland on Sunday night which the
Lakers started off with a 14 point lead
in the early moments and then they were
behind by 25 points at halftime and so I
kind of drifted away to something else
and then I you know I keep looking at my
phone and all falling into stores every
night and then I see it's a game again
and then the Lakers win it going away
now they got rui hatchimora yeah wow
anything is possible if in in the NBA
today if you win four games in a row
you're skyrocketing up the standings
because everybody is so bunched in and
nothing's been determined yet but is
there too much scoring bill it's almost
like baseball where there's too many
home runs and there's too many
three-pointers
no it's fine it's what the rules are and
the the scientists and this was Mike
D'Antoni who saved basketball would the
game be better if we removed the
three-point line no I love the
three-point line and it was so fantastic
I remember one night we were playing you
know I mean in the early days at a
three-point it was started in 79 and and
rest in peace Chris Ford who just passed
away made the first three-pointer and so
we're playing in the Boston Garden and
you know I'm not really playing I'm
sitting on the bench cheering for Larry
and Kevin and Chief and DJ and Danny and
Larry's having a monster game Monster
game and in the Boston Garden is just
rocking it's against the Knicks and
Hubie Brown his coaching and Patrick
Ewing and and Bernard King and all these
guys right an excellent excellent team
but certainly not the Boston Celtics
with Larry Bird and Robert Parish and
Kevin McHale and DJ and Danny and the
second string that we had and the crowd
is going crazy Larry Larry Larry MVP I
mean the scoreboard is shaking right and
he'll be who was the coach of the Knicks
at the time now hubby as the broadcaster
at 89 and really ever since she became
the broadcaster who's been the model of
Decorah right but when he was the coach
I mean he was a fire brand over there
and he loved to yell at his own players
and when that didn't work he's already
yelling at us the other team and so
Larry's making three after three and and
and the ball rolls out of bounds right
to Hubie Brown who picks up the ball and
normally you just throw it back to the
rep and Larry comes running over there
because he doesn't want the game to stop
right and and Huey won't give Larry the
ball right and Larry's not trying to
grab it and the ref come to her what's
going on here and the crowd is just
stunned and everything and finally Larry
you know does get a hold of the ball but
Julie still won't give up the referee
comes in separates them and
and hear me looks at Larry and says oh
yeah Bird yeah you think you're so good
at making all these threes and firing
this crowd up here and torching the
dicks here on a Friday night in the
Boston Garden you think you're so good
bird you're making all these streets
let's see you bank one of those threes
in and Larry looked at like like Al
Pacino from Taxi Driver I I hope I got
Al and Robert in your life
yeah okay it was Robert De Niro
protector Larry the book said you'd be
like he's the taxi driver right he said
you you're talking to me but Larry just
who was already so on fire he grabs the
ball from The Ref throws it in gets it
right back right in front of you like a
foot from the sideline where the coaches
did right looks at Hubie and banks in a
three and then he spends the rest of the
game banking in everything
every time you just blare over here
you're looking at me you talking to me
oh my gosh oh did yeah today it is
superb these players
these players are staggeringly fit these
players are staggeringly skilled I mean
the dribbling the passing the shooting
the rebounding and it's just they're all
so gifted you know and with
with the selection of the players and
the development and what Bal what the
Africa initiative is between the NBA
Academy the Bal and and basketball
Without Borders which is you know these
are Global things but right now 25 of
the NBA 25 are international players
fantastic and David Stern you know he's
responsible for that what we all did
going around the world teaching the game
of basketball in the 90s our basketball
you know they had the business guys the
marketing guys the media guys the
organization guys but the basketball
team was Jack Ramsey Hubie Brown Calvin
Murphy and me and we got to go
everywhere once a month for a week and
it was just absolutely fantastic and now
you've got players like Dirk Nowitzki
and you've got players like Tony Parker
and Manu Ginobili from all over the
world and Boris Pio and you know the
globalization has been absolutely
fantastic and then and the money
Ken David Stern took a game turned into
a business a business that's now
generating 10 billion dollars a year and
you know our guests last night Phil
Knight we had Dr J Phil Knight and Adam
Sandler they were all just brilliant but
as David Stern the most important man in
the history of all basketball I've never
took a shot but he made the game into a
business and then Phil Knight the most
important man in the history of all
sports because he did that for All
Sports and Nike by itself makes more
money every year than the NFL the NBA
Major League Baseball uh hockey and the
NCAA combined and and it's just
incredible what they've been able to do
the the business the growth you look
back at the numbers and and the
skyrocketing graphs the hockey stick
graph and it's just phenomenal and we're
so grateful we're so happy he is uh Bill
Walton the Hall of Famer it's called
throw it down with Bill Walton it
streams exclusively on NBA league pass
the next matchup is Raptors Sons that'll
be Monday in the desert let's go hey oh
it's it's great to see you I'm glad
you're doing well I love Dan Patrick
thank you for having me thank you for
your patience yes thank you but Satan do
you want to say goodbye to Bill Walton
as Bill Walton Mr Walton we just keep on
rolling just a mile to go
roll away the dew yeah if my words did
glow like the gold of sunshine thank you
very well triple in Still Water where
there is no Pebble tossed nor wind to
blow thank you for having me thank you
for your patience thank you thank you
that is Bill Walton Hall of Fame he's
the best man all the famous I love him